Scusate degli appunti perché fisicamente
sto piuttosto bene ma la testa è
proprio preferisco avere una traccia
davanti per parlare di questo tema che
mi piace è un tema Vitale dinamico
presuppone un accadere delle cose Da
cosa nasce
cosa
Sì ma
cosa Cioè cos'è quella cosa che nasce
dall'incontro con un'altra cosa e genera
un'altra cosa ancora tra l'altro Cosa è
il termine più vago più inaffidabile e
approssimativo che esista
No e non ha una sua vera competenza la
parola
cosa Se c'è una cosa cosa che io detesto
è la vaghezza e l'incompetenza Ecco come
quando parlo con una mia amica che è
appassionata di ginton che ne beve uno
prima di cena e 5 o se dopo cena che mi
dice Sai ho visto un film con cosa che
era un quel film con regista coso che
faceva quel film su quella cosa che poi
cosava Ecco
Eppure la mia amica Sveva si ricorda di
tutto ha in testa tutto ciò che ha in sé
l'emozione di quella aff fassellari di
cose di cui parla cosa gli è rimasto di
quel film dove c'era coso che parlava di
cose che si ricordava di cose che poi ha
fatto un'altra cosa cos'è questa cosa
che
sopravvive ad ogni vaghezza ad ogni
incompetenza Che cos'è questa cosa che
andiamo cercando che è generata forse
dall'episodio dico o forse no
è qualcosa che non si subisce Ma che noi
stessi
generiamo che noi stessi cerchiamo come
una specie di caccia al
tesoro alla fine della quale noi
cerchiamo
qualcosa Ma cosa che cosa Io penso di
aver capito nella mia infinita
presunzione penso di aver capito Io
credo che questa cosa che cerchiamo è
una
cipolla Sì il celebre ortaggio da tubero
credo che si dica così verso cui noi
tutti spesso abbiamo ostilità perché va
sbucciata va tolta quella pellina gialla
così antipatica va va va Come si dice
scattiata Come si dice noi in Toscana ci
si impuzzolire
mangere cose che ci sono
insopportabili e anche se noi abbiamo la
certezza che poi quella cipolla porterà
a un soffritto che poi sarà usato per un
risotto meraviglioso che di cui godranno
i nostri amici sappiamo il senso di
quella cipolla
Eppure sappiamo che ci serve la cipolla
serve Eppure abbiamo sempre ostilità ad
avvicinare una cipolla perché una
cipolla buccia dopo buccia pianto dopo
pianto porta al cuore delle cose e che
cosa le cose da cui nascono altre cose
servono non perché accadono
Ma perché ci
rivelano Ma
cosa qual è il
significato che Alberga nel termine
cosa Allora mentre me lo domandavo ho
scoperto che come come spesso succede la
risposta è nella domanda le cose ci
rivelano il significato ci mostrano non
se stesse ma ciò che siamo noi e siamo
noi che detti la direzione tracciata da
quella cosa che poi porta al passo
successivo un'altra cosa e un'altra cosa
ancora in questo
caso se noi poniamo un tipo di
attenzione un tipo di visione un tipo di
sguardo alle cose che ci accadono
presupponendo che diamo un significato a
ciò che
accade che magari ci porta al centro di
noi stessi Beh Da cosa nasce cosa è una
cosa terrificante come modo di dire
perché presuppone un impegno e un
mettere in discussione se stessi e
accogliere il dubbio e uno sguardo
preciso al significato insomma un'ansia
a cosan St Ca Infatti è stato inventato
questo detto e Da cosa nasce cosa per
minimizzare TR
Allora
ehm parlerò della mia
esperienza ho capito che non serve
preoccuparsi ma piuttosto occuparsi
della cipolla e tendere a un buon
risotto non preoccuparsi del pianto che
spesso genera un'esperienza dopo l'altra
esperienza una cosa che porta a un'altra
cosa Una buccia tolta dopo un'altra
buccia ogni incontro ogni ciampo ogni
fallimento ogni conquista ogni
convinzione ogni casualità ha in sé una
rivelazione che può generare una
rivoluzione non ho mai notato fino a
quando non ho preso questi appunti che
rivelazione e rivoluzione sono parole
così simili e qual è la pretesa di una
rivoluzione Qual è la condizione
necessaria perché avvenga una
rivelazione e la
è l'ascolto del significato di quella
cosa che poi porterà a un'altra cosa in
modo
instancabile le cose sono instancabili
nel generare altre cose arrivare al
centro di noi stessi essere leali agire
la nostra
centralità e credo che sia un modo per
procedere della comunità a trovare un
senso sociale
e a me è successo So di non di uscire un
po' fuori tema ma non del tutto Sono
stata a Vicenza a fare uno spettacolo
teatrale ero in borghese quella
sera il mio assistente mi ha detto
Perché non andiamo a bere un gintonic io
certamente ho
accettato e siamo entrati in un bar di
Vicenza dove c'era un gruppo di inglesi
un po' ubriachi
ehm in quel momento ho avuto un po'
paura poi siamo usciti fuori ci hanno un
po' inseguiti e ho avuto veramente paura
in questo senso Spero di assolvere in
questo momento pur tradendo la signora
con i capelli bianchi che avete davanti
una funzione sociale ho avuto paura
ho pensato è questo che le donne provano
quando sono in pericolo è questo che le
donne provano quando sono vicine in
prossimità di una violenza Ecco e sono
qui a parlarvene è successa una cosa
sono andato a bere un gin tonic ho avuto
paura è successo un'altra cosa la
conseguenza e l'ascolto di quella cosa
di quella mia paura mi ha portato qui a
parlarvi la paura della della mia paura
in quel momento e a a dire a espormi
dicendo che forse è importante che gli
uomini anche parlino contro la violenza
delle
donne in un suo senso sta nella
partecipazione al Sociale sta nel e non
si può fare
se noi non abbiamo un vero contatto con
noi stessi e non stiamo in contatto con
le reazioni alle cose che poi portano
alle ad avere una relazione col la
reazione che poi porta delle rivoluzioni
che forse generano delle rivelazioni
reazioni relazioni rivelazioni
rivoluzioni mi piacciono i giochi di
parole mi piacciono le parole che stanno
insieme a braccetto come queste
E per quanto mi riguarda reazione
rivelazione relazione
rivoluzione mi fa sentire in azione
verso me
stesso verso me
stessa e
verso il mondo che mi circonda risotto
dopo
risotto pianto dopo pianto buccia dopo
buccia si arriva a comprendere ciò che
si è il Ted è un racconto di esperienze
e sposto questo mi hanno detto di non
uscire dalla luce
quindi vado a braccio Io sono stata Sono
un soggetto molto fortunato perché ho
ricevuto tante facilitazioni nella mia
vita ho dipinto sapevo dipingere
facilmente ho cantato sapevo cantare
facilmente Ho provato a far teatro ho
provato non ho provato non ho provato
appena B affacciato un talento Piccolo o
grande Insomma non sta a me giudicarlo
mi sono
subito inzuppata di pigrizia e di
spavento perché quel talento mi avrebbe
messo davanti a una cosa che poi portava
un'altra cosa che poi portava un'altra
cosa che era la responsabilità del mio
talento Poi un giorno ho incontrato
Franco godi un bel signore e per una
serie di circostanze abbiamo lavorato
insieme e mi ha obbligato
impegnando se stesso investendo su di me
e anche altre persone aare contatto con
un mio con un mio talento questa cosa ha
generato l'approvazione ha generato la
soddisfazione ha generato uno spettacolo
ha generato il cinema la televisione ha
generato tante cose ma
soprattutto si è trasformata avendo
avuto ascolto
e reazione
e avendo accolto la rivelazione
che è che che sta nel prendersi
responsabilità di ciò che si è di ciò
che si può fare per se stessi ma
anche come funzione sociale
sottolineo poi ho fatto dei video in un
momento della pandemia io non sapevo
cosa sarebbe successo per me era
semplicemente Finalmente una vacanza
invece mi hanno un po' obbligato a fare
questi video perché bisognava essere un
po' presenti sul web E comunque esporsi
da questo tema ho fatto questi video e
ho fatto compagnia a me stessa e alle
persone che hanno seguito i miei piccoli
scherzi telefonici con la mia orrenda
domestica
ehm e
questo stando dentro a questa cosa
affrontata con un po' di pigrizia un po'
di senso di dovere poi ho capito essendo
in relazione con So ciò che stavo
facendo che forse era un luogo adatto
per parlare di cose importanti Allora ho
iniziato a parlare di cose che mi stanno
a cuore la discriminazione la violenza
sulle donne ed altri temi
e ho iniziato ad essere ehm Questo è il
contro all rovescia Oddio che ansia ma
se sforo cosa succede
scoppio va bene
Oh sono portata un po' al sermone
ehm Eh ho scoperto che il la percezione
del mio personaggio del mio lavoro è
cambiata non ero più una confezione
finalmente nessuno mi considerava una NB
donna Fiorentina da salotto che tra
l'altro è un luogo che detesto
preferisco di gran lunga la cucina o il
bagno dove siamo tutti in modo
democratico e per lo stesso motivo
trovo e e da quel momento in poi è stato
ascoltato il mio pensiero che Credetemi
per un artista è il privilegio più più
grande quindi stare dentro una cosa
doverla fare ma starci dentro col suo
significato accettare di sbucciare una
cipolla arrivare al cuore della cipolla
mi ha portato ad essere ascoltata mi ha
portato a Sanremo ad essere ascoltata e
mi ha portato
a guardare il senso del mio lavoro da un
altro punto di vista che non è solo
l'intrattenimento
Ma è un impegno di lealtà verso se
stessi e questo presuppone anche verso
le persone che mi seguono che ringrazio
quindi dopo tutto questo percorso di
cipolle di paure di pianti di
televisioni di sanremi di canzoni di
teatro Alla fine son qua sono quella che
sono e credo che alla fine 1 minuto e
19 Forse vi Canzo una
canzoncina
[Applauso]
[Musica]
I I am what I
am I am my own Special
Creation
so come Take a look Give me a Hook
[Musica]
the
my and I want to have
little my
and place I have
[Musica]
to
[Applauso]
I am what I am I don't want Pra I don't
want
PD i Bang My Own Drum Something Noise
Well I think it's
Pretty So What If I love Spar
andle Why Not TR to Things
[Musica]
from till you
canout
[Musica]
One life And
there so It's Time To Open up your
[Applauso]
[Musica]
CL Hey
World
ha
bravo